[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines toute la
rédaction TV 78 se joint à moi pour vous
souhaiter une belle et heureuse année
2023 tout de suite le programme de ce 2
janvier
chaque année amène son lot de changement
revalorisation du salaire minimum prime
pour le covoiturage fin de la remise
carburant il y a des bonnes mais aussi
quelques mauvaises nouvelles le point à
suivre dans cette émission l'année 2023
sera aussi sportive cela fait partie
sans doute de vos bonnes résolutions
quels sont les grands événements prévus
sur le territoire en matière de sport
quels sont les athlètes à suivre
absolument élément de réponse
et puis notre invité vient nous parler
d'espace l'astrophysicienne et astronome
Sarah entier Farfa réunis une trentaine
de scientifiques du monde entier à
partir de demain pour un colloque dans
les Yvelines tous membres de grandes
mains ce réseau de télescopes qu'elle a
fondé en 2018 et présent dans 18 pays 4
jours de rencontre au centre de
Port-Royal et de Saint-Lambert-des-Bois
où il sera notamment question du
phénomène d'onde gravitationnelle et
justement ça rentrait fort qui est avec
nous bonsoir donc je disais
astrophysicienne vous êtes basé à
l'Observatoire de la Côte d'Azur à Nice
enseignant un chercheur également et
membre du Conseil national des
astronomies physiciens vous êtes
civilinoise originaire de Voisins le
bretonneux vous avez reçu en 2018
puisque vous aviez été à l'époque
lauréate du Prix L'Oréal UNESCO qui a
récompense les femmes en sciences et
donc vous travaillez sur l'astronomie
qui édite multimé autrement dit vous
vous intéressez au phénomène très
violent de l'univers c'est ça oui c'est
ça des phénomènes violents donc
auparavant avant 2015 on les étudie
uniquement avec la lumière
et puis depuis 2015 on peut aussi capter
le signal d'onde gravitationnelle d'où
multi messager la lumière et les ondes
gravitationnelles
gravitationnelles pour vulgariser
globalement quand il y a un phénomène
extrêmement violent cela déforme
l'espace-temps et des ondes nous
parviennent jusqu'à la terre et on peut
les détecter depuis 2015 et donc pour
imager phénomène très violent on parle
de collision de trou noir par exemple
d'étoiles comme des étoiles à neutrons
ou bien l'effondrement d'une étoile en
fin de vie et on parlera tout à l'heure
de ce colloque vous organisez à partir
de demain dans les Yvelines les
informations du jour aussi à suivre dans
un instant ce sera avec vous Gabriel
Gontier bonsoir bonsoir alors de quoi
parle-t-on en ce deuxième jour de
l'année 2023 et bien ce soir Grégory
nous reviendrons sur l'appel à la grève
des médecins cette semaine notre chiffre
du jour sera consacré lui à la
démographie yvelinoise avec un chiffre
intéressant vous le verrez et notre
image du jour elle est sportive les
joueurs du FC Versailles se sont envolée
pour un stage de préparation au Maroc en
fait la transition parce qu'on parlera
justement de sport comme tous les lundis
dans le 7 8 alors pas de résultat
sportifs avec vous Michael bonsoir
Michael vidéo de la rédaction de Télé 78
journaliste sport et on va se projeter
avec vous sur l'année 2023 est-ce qu'il
y a un événement un ou une sportivation
suivre à ne pas manquer en 2023 pour les
passionnés de cycliste mais il y aura le
Tour de France qui passera par les
Yvelines par le vélodrome national de
saint-quent en ligne ce sera le 23
juillet prochain et au niveau des
sportifs il y en a beaucoup qu'il faudra
suivre l'année prochaine il y aura par
exemple Louis Burton qui sera sur la
Transat Jacques Vabre ou Caroline Garcia
qui pourrait peut-être remporter son
premier titre du Grand Chelem ce sera
lors de l'Open d'Australie qui commence
dans quelques jours en Australie pour
connaître ces événements c'est sportifs
bien sûr rester avec nous dans le 7 8 ce
sera tout à l'heure on parlera également
d’économie comment recruter en 2023 en
se posera la question et puis toute
cette semaine on jettera quelques coups
d'oeil dans le rétroviseur de 2022 pour
se remémorer les grand passer avec un
premier numéro ce soir mais qui dit
nouvelle année dit aussi bonne
résolution à faire un petit tour de
table quels sont vos bonnes résolutions
de l'année ça rendait fort fort
les deux à la fois réussir dans le
bonheur Michael plus de sport peut-être
c'est paradoxal mais je vais peut-être
faire plus de sport cette année en tout
cas c'est ma résolution faire plus de
sport le pratiquer en tout cas parce que
je regarde beaucoup à la télévision et
également sur les terrains le dimanche
mais par contre j'en fais pas tant que
ça j'aimerais bien en faire un peu plus
Gabriel je veux dire pareil en faire
plus de sport se coucher plus tôt enfin
les classiques qu'on fait pas forcément
mais bon on va essayer mon alimentation
après les les repas copieux des feux
d'art quels sont justement les les
bonnes résolutions nos yvelinois pour
2023 Julien Leroy et Ludivine canard
sont allés à leur rencontre regardez
réussir mes études scolaires ce serait
bien
et puis sortir un peu moins et ben j'y
ai pas forcément encore réfléchi mais je
crois que j'ai tout ce qu'il faut dans
la vie donc pour l'instant je ne vais
pas en prendre déjà je pense que je vais
me mettre un peu plus au sport
et sinon essayer de me manger enfin un
peu plus mes amis rentrer un peu plus
chez moi en Bretagne aussi là déjà
acheter moins de plastique et moins de
carton mais ça ferait peut-être que les
fabricants le pensent avant nous
j'espère avoir pour moi pour tout le
monde pour ma famille pour tout mon
entourage une bonne santé prospérité
plein de succès aussi je sais pas bien
me marrer profiter puis
je sais pas continuer d'arrêter de fumer
vous l'avez entendu du sport ça revient
souvent dans les résolutions aussi des
résolutions plus écologiques c'est en
phase avec le temps mais le plus dur
quand même c'est de les tenir c'est
bonne résolutions on verra si elles sont
tenues tout au long de l'année avant de
dérouler la suite du programme du 7 8 on
va jeter un petit coup d'œil à la météo
de demain
[Musique]
et après la douceur du week-end du
Nouvel An retour à des températures plus
normal demain matin dans le département
le ciel sera nuageux avec quelques
éclairs il fera 6 degrés à Rambouillet
Versailles et Houdan 5 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie condition similaire
l'après midi avec un thermomètre qui
grimpe légèrement compter 10 degrés dans
le nord et le centre du département il
devrait faire 9 degrés dans le sud à
Rambouillet ce mardi 3 janvier nous
fêterons les Geneviève
ça semblait intéresser Michael elmie
Doro cette dernière information on va
parler d'informations
de ce lundi de janvier avec vous Gabriel
et on débute avec le chiffre du jour oui
ce chiffre c'est un million
449723 c'est le nombre divinois selon
les nouvelles données publiées par
l'Insee alors il ne s'agit pas du
chiffre pour l'année 2023 mais de la
population au 1er janvier 2020 ce
chiffre démontre que la démographie dans
le département a légèrement ralenti
entre 2018 et 2019 nous étions 6800 de
plus alors qu'entre 2019 et 2020 on
compte seulement 1500 nouveaux yvelinois
alors il faut savoir que
Saint-Cyr-l'École La Queue-les-Yvelines
et carrière sous Poissy constituent les
villes avec la plus grande progression
d'habitants une grève présent qui est
reconduite pour une deuxième semaine
c'est la grève des médecins libéraux oui
je vous en parlais en début de journal
effectivement la grève est reconduite
jusqu'au 8 janvier le collectif dessin
pour demain prévoit une manifestation
nationale à Paris ce jeudi le collectif
estime que le gouvernement n'a pas
répondu à leurs attentes alors parmi les
revendications la revalorisation du
montant des consultants consultations de
25 à 50 euros qui permettait d'embaucher
qui permettraient d'embaucher du
personnel pour les tâches
administratives afin qu'ils puissent
puissent consacrer
uniquement aux tâches médicales
d'urgence ainsi votre médecin est en
grève privilégié plutôt le numéro 15 à
appeler plutôt que de vous rendre
directement dans les services d'urgence
à l'hôpital également des nouveautés du
côté des bus dans le cadre de
l'ouverture à la concurrence des autobus
franciliens francilité
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines du groupe
Lacroix SAVAC de le groupe de la Croix
SAVAC devient le nouvel opérateur pour
exploiter le réseau de bus des 12
communes de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il
remplace le réseau skibus qui exploitait
les lignes depuis 1975 alors des
modifications sont à prévoir sur les
lignes
qui relie Versailles chantier à Maurepas
village et 44 qui relie Versailles
chantier à Plaisir-Grignon leur nombre
de trajet et leur amplitude horaire et
renforcée en semaine les week-ends
du côté de Poissy l'image du jour
Gabriel elle concerne les joueurs du
Football Club de Versailles
Football Club j'ai du mal ce soir c'est
la reprise ils se sont envolés ce matin
depuis l'aéroport d'Orly direction le
Maroc pour un stage de préparation
physique l'objectif résoudre l'équipe en
vue des matchs dans les championnats
nationales alors pour la reprise ils
auront contre l'US Avranches ce sera le
13 janvier prochain l'équipe est
actuellement deuxième du championnat à
un point de l' US Concarneau
d'une montée des 7 saisons dans le
championnat de Ligue 2 pour terminer des
chèvres alors il y a aucun lien un mec
qui attendent d'être adopté oui ça
aurait pu être l'image du jour également
à 50 chefs qui sont provisoirement
hébergés à la ferme du hameau de la
reine à Versailles elles ont été
recueillies par l'association règne
animale après un signalement pour
maltraitance fin novembre et elle
n'attendent plus qu'à être adoptée en
tant qu'animo de compagnie alors si vous
souhaitez adopter ou proposer votre aide
un numéro s'affiche en bas de votre
écran merci Gabriel et si vous aussi
près de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'un
fait d'actualité qui vous fait réagir et
n'hésitez pas à le partager à le dire
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 7 8 news
on va faire un nouveau tour de table et
ce qu'il y a une actualité un fait
marquant qui vous a marqué justement sa
rentier Farfa en 2022 bien évidemment la
guerre en Ukraine puisque ça aussi
impacté les observations astronomiques
mais par exemple observatoire de Kim n'a
pas été touché ils ont continué à
observer sous les sous les bombardements
pour grands mains par exemple donc ça
m'a aussi marqué la petite histoire
personnelle parce que ils sont vraiment
héroïques ces Ukrainiens aussi c'est
scientifique ukrainien en février qui se
poursuit toujours nickel moi je dirais
je crois que c'était en septembre le
décès de la Reine Elisabeth il y a eu
une minute dommage notamment à la
British School à Croissy-sur-Seine
forcément où il y avait énormément de
d'élèves britanniques et
l'école quasiment 100% britannique et
voilà il y a eu un moment d'émotion et
oui je pense que c'est mis des images
qui m'a marqué depuis septembre dans les
Yvelines la dernière événement qui vous
a marqué spécialement dans les Yvelines
dans les Yvelines et c'est un peu plus
récent mais je dirais la Coupe du monde
de football on en a beaucoup parlé ici
donc
presque une victoire de l'équipe de
France malheureusement et une finale que
beaucoup divinement ont pu suivre au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
il y a environ 6000 personnes je crois
au fait le Drôme national de 50 ans en
Yvelines et beaucoup d'ivinois dont vous
je crois Gabriel donc forcément ça vous
aurez de la rédaction
et donc toute cette semaine TV 70
revient justement sur sur ces faits
marquants on va prendre notre machine à
remonter le temps pour voir ce qu'il
s'est passé l'année dernière dans les
Yvelines une première rétrospective ce
soir de janvier à mars 2022 et c'est
avec Céline Charles un début d'année
encore marqué par l'épidémie du covid 19
face à la flambée des contaminations
quotidiennes le gouvernement annonce de
nouvelles mesures le télétravail devient
obligatoire trois jours par semaine dans
les entreprises et il est interdit de
consommer debout dans les bars et
restaurant en politique le maire de
Mantes-la-Jolie Raphaël cogner
démissionne début janvier une résultante
du conflit qui l'oppose au président du
conseil départemental et éliminal Pierre
Bédier de nouvelles élections sont
programmées six candidats sont en liste
pour le poste côté sport un premier
semestre en grande pompe pour le
football yvelinois en janvier le FC
Versailles accède au 8e de finale de la
Coupe de France c'est historique pour le
club après une victoire contre Toulouse
1-0 et un succès au tir au but contre
Bergerac Versys en demi-finale mais
l'ascension s'arrête ici le club est
éliminé contre Nice 2-0 sport toujours
la sixième semaine olympique et
paralympique organisée par le Comité
d'Organisation Paris 2024 et l'éducation
nationale fait son retour dans le
département cette année les thèmes sont
l'environnement et le climat à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines 600 enfants
découvrent les sites olympiques de
l'agglomération enfin Rima Ayadi
conserve son titre de championne
continental de WBBA des léger lors du
troisième gala de boxe aux Mureaux c'est
aussi le début de la campagne
présidentielle Emmanuel Macron a tenu sa
toute première réunion publique à Poissy
sur comme le pouvoir d'achat
l'immigration ou encore la guerre en
Ukraine la Russie a envahi l'Ukraine au
mois de février c'est le retour de la
guerre en Europe face au départ massif
dukrainien l'État et les collectivités
se mobilisent pour les accueillir des
rassemblements concerts et mobilisations
sont effectuées un peu partout dans le
département en plein conflit ukrainien
Emmanuel Macron réunis les chefs d'État
et de gouvernement de l'Union européenne
pour un sommet européen au château de
Versailles plusieurs décisions sont
prises notamment la sortie de la
dépendance de la Russie concernant le
gaz et le pétrole d'ici 2027 ou encore
des investissements stratégiques autour
de la défense côté culture les Yvelines
célèbre Molière à l'occasion des 400 ans
de sa naissance l'espace richo à
Versailles accueille l'exposition
Molière qui retrace la vie mais aussi
l'héritage culturel du dramaturge
Saint-Germain-en-Laye présente aussi
Molière en couleur à la médiathèque Marc
fero après l'UVS Cussac le laboratoire
atmosphère observation spatiale
travaille sur un nouveau nano satellite
inspire sad 7 sera mise en orbite en
janvier 2023 il réalisera des
observations pendant au moins deux ans
de notre terre et de son climat à 550 km
d'altitude enfin ils nous ont quitté au
premier semestre 2022 l'architecte
espagnole Ricardo beaufil qui avait
notamment participé à la construction de
600 logements à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et à la
conception des arcades du lac de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et Jean-Pierre
Pernaut à l'âge de 71 ans le journaliste
résidait à Louveciennes dans les
Yvelines
cette semaine on nous reviendrons sur
ces événements marquants demain deuxième
focus avec les événements marquants des
mois d'avril à juin Maurice projeté à
présent sur l'année 2023 Gabriel ne
vivons pas trop dans le dans le passé
des choses ont changé au premier janvier
et c'est appliqué tous les ans vous avez
l'habitude le passage à la nouvelle
année s'accompagne de nouvelles mesures
en voici quelques-unes qui risquent de
vous concerner alors on commence avec la
revalorisation du SMIC le salaire
minimum de croissance augmente de 1,81%
dès le premier janvier le montant du
SMIC augmentera de 24 euros nets comptez
un salaire mensuel à 1709 euros brut
pour 35 heures l'année dernière
l'augmentation du SMIC elle concernait
2,5 millions de personnes à noter que
l'Île-de-France n'est pas la région la
plus concernée parce que le salaire
moyen en Île-de-France est quand même
plus élevé que dans les autres régions
de France mais aussi du côté des
retraités il y a également une hausse
oui tout à fait celle de la pension de
retraite de base qui augmente cette fois
de 0,8 intéressant alors c'est 14
millions de Français qui sont concernés
au 31 décembre 2021 le nombre de
retraités s'élevé à un million 933 752
en Île-de-France
plus que jamais cette année et le
gouvernement veut encourager le
covoiturage oui cette réforme fera
peut-être de des Yvelines en tout cas un
territoire plus verte c'est ce qui
espère le gouvernement en encourageant
le covoiturage avec une prime de 100
euros pour les primo conducteurs dans le
cadre du plan national covoiturage du
quotidien alors cette prisme elle
concerne les nouveaux inscrits sur les
plateformes de covoiturage comme
blablacar ou encore Carros justement ça
pourrait pousser davantage
d'utilisateurs à se tourner vers le
covoiturage on vous en parlait il y a
quelques semaines c'est maintenant
officiel depuis le 1er janvier le Pass
Navigo le prix du passe Navigo augmenté
oui et il s'élève à 94 euros et 10
centimes c'est le montant mensuel de ce
Pass Navigo à compter du 1er janvier une
augmentation de 12% donc en cause
l'inflation l'annonce elle a été faite
par Île-de-France mobilité présidée par
Valérie Pécresse qui est président du
Conseil régional d'Île-de-France cette
hausse elle a quand même été à moindre
riz grâce au déblocage par l'état de 200
millions d'euros sans lequel
l'abonnement serait passé à 90 euros
qui risque d'impacter notre
porte-monnaie avec la fin de la
ristourne sur le carburant oui que ce
soit dans les 238 stations des Yvelines
ou partout en France fini les 10
centimes d'euros par litre de carburant
pris en charge par l'État mais attention
cette prime est remplacée par une
indemnité qui est réservée aux
travailleurs les plus modestes
l'indemnité elle célèbre à 100 euros
alors si vous souhaitez faire la demande
rendez-vous sur le site
impot.gouvernement.fr merci Gabriel pour
ces nouveautés du mois de janvier de
l'année 2023 une année 2023 avec de
grands événements on aura l'occasion de
parler de sport dans un instant avec
vous Michael alors l'un des premiers
événements de cette année 2023 va se
dérouler à partir de demain je vous le
disais en début d'édition c'est jusqu'à
jeudi au centre jusqu'à vendredi même
jusqu'au centre de Port-Royal à
Saint-Lambert-des-Bois en Vallée de
Chevreuse une trentaine de physiciens et
astronomes du monde entier seront
présents un événement qui organisé par
vous Sarah entier Fafa je le rappelle
donc vous êtes yvelinoise
astrophysicienne astronome également
juste pour préciser pour noter les
spectateurs d'où viennent ces
scientifiques qui seront présents à
partir de demain donc ils seront un peu
de temps ils viennent de la
collaboration grand-mai il se répartis
dans le monde donc en Asie par exemple
en Ouzbékistan aussi en Asie centrale
Azerbaïdjan Géorgie et puis aussi aux
Amériques États-Unis
Brésil sans compter sur évidemment
l'Europe donc la France l'Espagne donc
c'est on imagine difficile de tous les
réunir au même endroit sur un sur un
créneau c'est vraiment très difficile
mais on a réussi qui avait un
représentant par pays pour venir à cette
cette ce colloque et vous avez parlé de
grandes mains très intéressants très
important c'est le réseau de télescope
que vous avez fondé en 2018 il regroupe
du pays et sans membres on disait tout à
l'heure vous travaillez sur l'astronome
l'astronomie dite multimé qui
s'intéresse au phénomène très violent de
notre univers et donc ces phénomènes
sont détectés grâce aux signal lumineux
et aux ondes gravitationnelles avoir ce
réseau de télescope assez étoffé et
présent dans toute la planète c'est
important justement pour ne pas louper
ce qui de ce qui se passe dans le ciel
finalement les événements de ce qui se
passe dans le ciel oui effectivement en
fait ce sont des phénomènes
cataclysmiques violents qui en fait
interviennent n'importe quand et
n'importe où sur la vie sur la voûte
céleste et comme on le sait on observe
pas le même ciel dans l'hémisphère Nord
et dans l'hémisphère sud donc quand un
événement arrive long lumineuse arrive
sur la terre il faut pouvoir le détecter
très rapidement parce que l'éclat de
cette de ce signal diminue dans les
heures voire dans les jours qui viennent
donc ces phénomènes sont très rares
et donc du coup il faut pas laisser
passer sa chance et donc d'avoir des
télescopes qui observent au sol permet
d'être toujours en alerte et de se tenir
à l'affût de ces phénomènes violents et
donc d'observer ces ondes
gravitationnelles la prochaine campagne
d'observation aura lieu cette année au
printemps 2023 c'est ça donc la dernière
avait été avait fini en mars 2020 et
donc trois ans après les détecteurs dont
de gravitationnelles qui ne sont pas des
télescopes en fait sont remis en route
sont déjà remis en route mais ont été
peaufinés pour voir plus loin et ça
permet en fait de voir des événements
plus loin et d'être plus sensibles et de
récolter encore davantage un signal plus
fort dans le gravitationnel donc
détecter on le disait des phénomènes
très violents parfois même cataclysmique
en octobre il y a un sursaut gamma qui
n'avait été jamais observé jusqu'à lors
qu'il a pu être détecté grâce à grande
main c'est ça c'est ça en fait c'est un
sursaut gamma donc un sursaut gamma
comme le l'indique c'est des bouffées de
photos gamma qu'on n'observe pas depuis
le sol puisque les photons gamma sont
arrêtés par l'atmosphère et donc c'est
un télescope plusieurs télescopes même
des cupsat qui sont d'ailleurs aussi
montés à 50 ans
ont été capable aussi de détecter ces
bouffer gamin qui ont envoyé des alertes
aux astronomes au sol et qu'on a suivi
la contrepartie visible le signal
lumineux optique et donc en main a fait
partie de cette campagne de suivi pour
capter l'ensemble de ce qui se passe de
ce sursaut gamma donc pour le grand
public le sursaut gamma c'est le témoin
d'un G qui vient qui a été mis après la
formation d'un nouvel objet compact un
trou noir qui en fait
s'est formé suite à la l'inclosion d'une
étoile très très massive et donc ce
phénomène a été évoqué dans la presse en
octobre pourquoi parce que il était très
proche et c'était le plus lumineux qu'on
n'est jamais observé depuis l'histoire
de l'humanité et donc grand m'a observé
pendant plus d'un mois alors on part de
petit télescope de télescope amateur
mais il y a aussi un sweat derrière au
bout d'un mois de télescopes très très
sensibles comme comme les autres par
exemple si vous parlez de télescope
amateur ce qu'il est aussi intéressant
de dire c'est grande main donc regroupe
des des télescopes professionnels mais
aussi des astronomes amateurs en fait
qui se joignent à cet effort c'est ça et
qui comme on l'a montré en octobre on
prie en fait part à ses observations et
pour moi c'est très émouvant de voir ces
données scientifiques ou s'intercale des
télescopes très très puissants les plus
puissants de la planète par exemple à
Hawaï ou alors même le James web voilà
qui a été aussi
des belles images de l'espace et donc
des données des astronomes amateurs qui
ont aussi observé aussi en Vallée de
Chevreuse et et chelseweb ou d'autres
télescopes très puissants
question Gabriel non parce que
je m'y connais pas forcément comment
vous faites pour justement vulgariser un
peu tous ces termes qui sont un peu
compliqués pour nous qui connaissent pas
tout à l'heure mais c'est pas forcément
simple
tout ça c'est un peu compliqué mais en
gros toute cette science là des
phénomènes violents elle vient des
restes d'étoiles et beaucoup de
personnes me demandent mais pourquoi
qu'est-ce qu'on étudie ok on collecte la
lumière qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et bien
en fait c'est au cœur de ces phénomènes
violents sont créés des éléments
chimiques que l'on côtoie tous par
exemple l'événement de 2017 a montré
comment était fabriqué l'or mais c'est
aussi au cœur de ses effondrements des
toiles massives que par exemple on a
aussi d'autres éléments chimiques comme
le faire ou d'autres éléments lourds
donc en fait ces éléments que l'on
connaît sur Terre en fait ils sont créés
par ces phénomènes extrêmement violents
et pour moi c'est un lien en fait entre
notre quotidien
et ces phénomènes qui se sont déroulés
il y a beaucoup beaucoup
que vous organisez du coup l'objectif
pourquoi réunir tous ces scientifiques
quel est l'objectif de ces quatre jours
c'est parce que la terre tourne donc on
ne travaille pas au même ciseaux
horaires tout simplement et donc d'avoir
un échange où on est de façon synchrone
en train de travailler où on peut parler
en face à face permet du brainstorming
permet de de vraiment uniformiser toutes
nos techniques observationnelles parce
que évidemment la diversité c'est un
plus mais encore faut-il la contrôler et
donc ce workshop on va les Chevreuse
permet vraiment de de rassembler nos
forces et d'être vraiment aligné pour
cette campagne obser d'observation des
phénomènes donc gravitation qui va durer
un an il faut vraiment être dans la
c'est une course de fond en fait il faut
vraiment
c'est de la rencontre en cas de à la
rencontre c'est aussi des sortes de jeux
de rôle pour dire voilà si ce passe tel
événement qu'est-ce qu'on fait c'est
aussi il y a des des jeunes femmes
ingénieurs qui travaillent à la défense
qui tu dis à la défense qui vont venir
qui elle ont une expertise plutôt en web
développement ton sécurité web et qui
ont participé à ce programme pour
connaître l'astronomie alors qu'elle
n'était pas du tout du milieu et qui
vont coder pour permettre à la
plateforme d'échanger les données par
exemple c'est pas l'astrophysicien qui a
ses compétences là et pour moi ça fait
tout un écosystème pour vraiment aussi
démontrer la science astrophysique
moderne de demain et cet écosystème dont
on a besoin dans cette révolution
multimissager de mettre toutes ces
personnes en relation et donc cette
rencontre on le disait va se dérouler à
partir de demain au centre de Port-Royal
à Saint-Lambert-des-Bois merci sans
rentier fort fort d'être venu en parler
je rappelle astrophysicienne et
astronome originaire des Yvelines aller
à présent dans le 7 8 on va faire un peu
de sport et ça ne va pas faire de mal
j'en ai j'en ai du mal j'ai du mal à le
dire également ça n'a pas faire de mal
après les fêtes
[Musique]
et le sport c'est bien sûr avec vous
Michael el midoro 2023 on l'a dit sera
une année sportive dans le département
des Yvelines on va parler des événements
à ne pas manquer sur le territoire cette
année mais on va commencer par les
sportifs à suivre en 2023 oui et il y
aura du beau monde à suivre tout au long
de cette année à 2023 je vais commencer
par un nom qui va sûrement nous faire
rêver dans les prochaines années celui
de Victor web bagnama le sportif
originaire du général concours qui fait
trace ce mercredi 4 janvier c'est 19 ans
va terminer la saison avec les
métropolitains 92 il pourrait remporter
le championnat de France le club est
actuellement deuxième de la Betclic
Elite la première division française
mais Victor maniama pourrait surtout
intégrer la NBA lors de la draft 2023
programmé en mai le sportif de 2 mètres
21 devrait être numéro 1 de cette draft
une performance qu'aucun français n'a
jamais à réussi il pourrait être drafté
par les Spurs de son Antonio le Magic
d'Orlando ou les Hornets de Charlotte
mais rien n'est encore fait chacune de
ces sorties escutées avec attention de
l'autre côté de l'Atlantique par les par
les Américains qui rêvent déjà de Victor
Hugo mais il est français il est même
des Yvelines il reste bien français et
Yvelines c'est important de le rappeler
il y a un navigateur aussi à suivre
cette année Louis Burton originaire de
la selle les bords près de Rambouillet
va participer fin octobre 2023 à la
transat Jacques va avec son bateau
Bureau Vallée 3 il aura à cœur de
rebondir avec une de après une dernière
Route du Rhum difficile où il avait dû
abandonner après quelques jours de
course il avait une nouvelle fois dématé
cette fois-ci il va tenter de tester son
bateau afin d'être prêt pour 2024 et le
Vendée Globe après la mère la piste une
cycliste dont on attend beaucoup elle
nous a fait rêver en 2022 et elle va
sûrement continuer à nous éblouir en
2023 la nouvelle star française de la
piste mathildegro qui s'entraîne au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
va tenter de conserver son titre de
championne du monde de vitesse Aquila
une dernière elle va défendre son titre
à Glasgow en Écosse sur le
l'événement est programmé du 12 au 16
octobre une équipe également à suivre et
c'est une équipe de football le FC
Versailles sera l'équipe ivinoise à
suivre en 2023 après une magnifique
année 2022 et une demi-finale de Coupe
de France les joueurs de la cité royale
vont encore nous faire vibrer en 2023
ils sont éliminés de la Coupe de France
mais ils sont actuellement deuxième du
championnat de National à un petit point
du leader Concarneau non avoué par les
dirigeants l'objectif de la montée en
Ligue 2 et jouable pour cette année 2023
on espère revivre de belles émotions
avec ses Versailles j'étais en train de
se préparer on l'a dit du côté du Maroc
avec un stage effectué par les
footballeurs Yvelines noires pour monter
en Ligue 2 on termine par du tennis côté
athlète il faudra suivre Caroline Garcia
cette année on y croyait plus mais la
native de Saint-Germain-en-Laye a réussi
le tour de force de remporter le master
ce WTA une première pour le tennis
français depuis Amélie Mauresmo en 2005
elle a aussi fait une première
demi-finale en Grand Chelem à l'US Open
et a remporté quatre titres en 2022 mais
en 2023 les viennoises de 29 ans
espèrent faire mieux et remporter un
Grand Chelem première étape dès ce mois
de janvier avec l'Open d'Australie qui
débutera le 16 janvier nous voilà pour
les sportifs mais il y a encore des
sportifs
sont également à suivre en 2023 très
rapidement la numéro 1 du tennis foncé
Arthur renders
qui participera au tournoi des 6 nations
et le golfeur à Versailles Antoine
rosener qui tentera de remporter de
nouveaux titres cette année
malheureusement on ne peut pas tous les
citer mais il y en a beaucoup en la
compris des ibinois qui brillent nous
voilà pour les sportifs j'étais
impatient de connaître les grands
événements sportifs
je vous conseille alors pour les fans de
cyclisme le Tour de France 2023 passera
par les Yvelines le 23 juillet prochain
les coureurs selon du Vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines pour rejoindre les
Champs-Élysées à l'occasion de la
traditionnelle dernière étape le
vélodrome qui sera si olympique pour
2024 les coureurs passeront également
par d'autres communes zivinoises comme
Les Clayes-sous-Bois plaisir et
l'encours ou encore Guyancourt mais le
tracé reste à préciser on a l'habitude
de dire que les Yvelines sont une terre
de cyclisme mais il y aura d'ailleurs
encore le Paris-Nice une nouvelle fois
cette année exactement la 80 uneième
édition de la Course au Soleil partira
une nouvelle fois des Yvelines le 5 mars
prochain comme tous les ans depuis à 14
ans des stars du cyclisme sont attendus
dans le 78 mais la liste n'est pas
encore arrêtée en connaîtra
officiellement ce jeudi à 5 janvier le
parcours définitif il sera présenté à
l'hôtel du département à Versailles du
golf également l'Open de France de golf
reviendra pour une nouvelle édition
cette année en 2023 le plus vieil open
continental se tiendra du 21 au 24
septembre au Golf National de 50 ans en
Yvelines moins d'un an avant la tenue
des Jeux Olympiques sur ce site qui
succédera à l'italien Guido miguelosi au
palmarès réponse en septembre pour
l'instant la liste des participants
n'est évidemment pas arrêtée mille doré
t'y avoir des têtes d'affiches
françaises et notamment le Versailles
Antoine rosener milieu dit milieu gle on
va dire qu'on les fusionne voilà pour la
preuve de session française vous avez le
temps encore de vous entraîner pour
l'Open de France 2023 et enfin de la
course à pied pour terminer le Paris
Versailles sera organisé le 24 septembre
2023 l'événement réunit chaque année
plus de 25000 coureurs c'est quoi un jeu
partent de la Tour Eiffel gravis la
redoutable code des gardes à Meudon et
termine avenue de Paris au pied du
château environ à 17 km ce sera la 44e
édition entre Paris et la cité royale si
vous êtes intéressé n'hésitez pas à vous
inscrire rapidement les places sont très
chères intéressés peut-être Gabriel pour
le Paris Versailles 17 km ça va oui ça
va
on va partir sur du 10 km voilà on
s'inscrit on va s'inscrire tous ensemble
pour cette année 2023 qui est une année
très sportive on l'a compris vous êtes
Paris ou Michael je suis pas rien pour
2023 je vais être sur tous les
événements ne vous inquiétez pas merci
pour toutes ces précisions
il y a quelques jours TV 78 vous
proposer une émission consacrée à
l'emploi en collaboration avec la
startup de formation au numérique star
tag après une année 2022 particulière au
niveau de l'emploi comment les
entreprises ont-elles recruter en 2023
regardez cette interview avec trois
dirigeants d'entreprises autour de
Nicolas dandry
[Musique]
la principale préoccupation les dit en
tant que dirigeant d'entreprise que vous
êtes Yann Jean-Paul et Kevin qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez dire concernant vos
recrutements c'est tout à fait ça en
fait c'est une partie intégrante de
notre journée de notre quotidien de
recruter des de chercher en fait sur des
sur les plateformes les bons candidats
et de d'essayer de les attirer et puis
aussi après les fidéliser dans notre
secteur dans l'informatique le marché
particulièrement tendu et les candidats
reçoivent beaucoup beaucoup de
sollicitations donc on a besoin de de
passer du temps sur les plateformes pour
essayer de trouver les meilleurs profils
oui parce que faut dire que c'est 50 ans
en Yvelines et spécialisée dans la
distribution de produits informatiques
et assurer aussi les services
informatiques vous Jean-Paul miner c'est
la distribution de d'infrastructures
dédiée aux personnes à mobilité réduite
en quoi vous êtes touché par ces
difficultés de recrutement nos
difficultés de recrutement sont
principalement sur sur des postes qui
sont moins gérés moi technique que ceux
de l'anglais de chez exéciste et
apprendre demande pas des capacités et
des grandes connaissances techniques
mais
globalement c'est une activité numérique
en quoi vous êtes touché par ce sujet
parce que c'est numérique on le sait
c'est un métier en tension oui
effectivement c'est un métier en tension
nous sommes touchés par cette réalité il
faut au niveau du recrutement jouer mon
confrère des effets en ce sens que on a
l'impression d'avoir une réalité
paradoxal on a besoin de de diplômés de
jeunes talentueux et sur le marché il y
a des jeunes qui en chaises mais on
n'arrive pas à se marcher ensemble
pourquoi j'ai du mal à comprendre
peut-être qu'un besoin de formation on
en discutera tout à l'heure mais on a
vraiment un réel problème de recruter
des jeunes dans le domaine du numérique
des développeurs et puis des consultants
innovations c'est du technique mais on a
des talents en France il faudrait qu'on
arrive à se trouver et on va en parler
justement on parle bien évidemment vous
l'avez dit un de formation numérique
avec Virginie mais d'abord justement
arriver à matcher qui ira je me tourne
vers vous directrice de Pôle emploi de
Rambouillet est-ce que vous pourriez me
décrire un peu la conjoncture sur le
marché de l'emploi est-ce qu'elle est
inédite aujourd'hui ce qu'on connaît
actuellement alors oui elle est inédite
c'est vrai que la demande d'emploi a
baissée de manière significative ou
disiez plus de 8% depuis ce début
d'année dans le même temps on a une
augmentation très significative
également des projets de recrutement
enfin des embauches qui ont augmenté
depuis ce début d'année depuis 17%. un
taux de chômage dans les Yvelines qui
qui est totalement autour des 6%, 6,3%.
donc de détention sur le marché du
travail effectivement un écart entre les
compétences disponibles sur le marché du
travail et les compétences recherchées
par les recruteurs
comment on peut répondre à ça mais c'est
notre quotidien à Pôle Emploi notre
sujet c'est bien d'agir sur ces tensions
de recrutement et nous avons
700 collaborateurs sur les Yvelines et
70 chargées de relations entreprises et
on renforce encore aujourd'hui nos
équipes pour accompagner les projets de
recrutement des entreprises et proposer
des solutions adaptées à chaque
difficulté donc on a en fait une
stratégie à deux mailles
avec une stratégie impactante sur le
marché du travail avec une orientation
d'achat de formation pour pouvoir
développer suffisamment de compétences
disponibles sur le marché du travail et
également un bouquet de service où là on
est en capacité d'aller davantage dans
du sur-mesure et accompagner chaque
entreprise et proposer une solution
adaptée à son projet de recrutement
on vient de voir des images de rugby
alors je tiens à le préciser Pôle emploi
et le rugby sont liés parce qu'en fait
vous avez une initiative innovante de
recruter du stade vers l'emploi l'idée
c'est de faire rencontrer recruteur et
candidats à travers le sport finalement
je me tourne vers les dirigeants
justement vous seriez prêt à jouer au
rugby avec un futur collaborateur ou pas
ça dépend de la taille du collaborateur
en question ça dépend ce qu'on appelle
jouer avec mais en tout cas oui ce sont
des profits qui nous intéressent
beaucoup d'ailleurs notre groupe en fait
défi est très très axé faire le vers le
sport santé sport qui est important chez
nous avec des coachs en interne donc
effectivement c'est des profils qui nous
intéressent recrutés par le sport
Jean-Paul et Kevin rugby volontiers je
dirais très volontiers ce qui est
surtout intéressant c'est de au-delà
au-delà d'un CV c'est d'aller découvrir
le jurait le tempérament et l'envie de
la personne c'est ça qui est plus
important et l'esprit d'équipe parce que
c'est vraiment les fondamental pour
l'intégration dans nos entreprises on
reparlera de ces fameux soft skills mais
d'abord forcément les compétences la
formation Virginie ça c'est votre
spécialité
durant la semaine vous avez accompagné
des candidats pour booster justement
leur employabilité à travers l'outil
numérique en quoi aujourd'hui l'outil
numérique est indispensable pour trouver
un emploi et même pour les entreprises
essayer de trouver le bon collaborateur
en fait on les a accompagnés sur un
programme chaque jour avec une
thématique différente l'idée c'était
d'apprendre à raconter son histoire
parce que on a tous une belle histoire à
raconter encore faut-il savoir se vendre
et en tout cas bien la raconter parfois
on a peu de temps pour convaincre
d'ailleurs aussi savoir communiquer sur
les réseaux sociaux est-ce que c'est
vrai que c'est une vraie problématique
aujourd'hui
on peut on peut ne être visible et donc
l'idée c'était de leur montrer qu'on
peut vraiment exister avoir de la
visibilité grâce à LinkedIn on les a
accompagne également avec des outils
comme quand va pour refaire quand on va
pour refaire leur CV habiller un peu
leur profil pour que ce soit bien plus
marketé parce qu'en fait c'est vraiment
ça et surtout leur faire prendre
conscience qu'en fait la communication
séminaire de la guerre aujourd'hui il
faut se rendre visible des bons
employeurs il faut cibler sa recherche
pas peine de taper partout et très large
mais en tout cas en ayant les bonnes
techniques ça a fonctionné parce qu'on
parlera du bilan mais en tout cas on est
très contents
tous ces candidats en tout cas les
considérer qu'on suit le programme on
décrochait un entretien donc cette
semaine donc en 4 jours finalement
tous ont eu des prises de contact donc
entre 1 et 3 employeurs minimum on va
les suivre pendant trois semaines encore
donc le problème s'arrête pas là mais on
se rend compte qu'effectivement elles
ont pris conscience que finalement
parfois avec un poste on pouvait taguer
un bon employeur et se rendre visible et
attirer l'attention et du coup ouvrir le
dialogue et donc c'est plateforme de
candidature finalement c'est pas un
envoi de CV simple c'est ouvrir une
discussion et montrer qu'on a de
l'intérêt et montrer qu'on s'intéresse
au sujet prouvé en fait par
l'exemplarité que c'est notre sujet et
c'est nous la bonne personne quoi donc
effectivement c'est très bien fonctionné
très content depuis le début de
l'émission communique et matcher essayer
de me faire matcher un poste avec un bon
collaborateur et là je me tourne vers
vous quiera par rapport à Pôle Emploi
comment justement améliorer tout ça et
quels sont les méthodes peut-être
innovantes que vous allez mettre en
place en 2023 au niveau de Pôle emploi
alors c'est pour suivre les opérations
du stade vers l'emploi vous disiez que
vous étiez effectivement en recherche de
profil des opérations telles que le
stade vers l'emploi donne l'opportunité
à un candidat de démontrer des qualités
professionnelles des qualités
relationnelles comme la capacité à
travailler en équipe la capacité à
interagir avec avec
des candidats qui sont là
capacités également à respecter des
consignes à faire preuve de persévérance
de se positionner comme un leader donc
ces opérations permettent effectivement
de sortir un peu de cet entretien un peu
formel qui peut être anxiogène pour
certains candidats donc on poursuit ces
opérations et puis c'est toute notre
ingénierie recrutement que l'on mobilise
au quotidien pour les entreprises ça
peut aller de l'analyse de poste pour
accompagner notamment des petites
structures dans la qualification de
leurs besoins anticiper sur les
problématiques de recrutement en
confrontant au marché du travail et
derrière c'est toute l'ingénierie autour
de comment on va pouvoir proposer des
solutions pour adapter des candidats à
des besoins à vos profils de poste et
également notre offre de service s'est
enrichie depuis le mois de septembre
avec une ingénierie formation pour
accompagner et aider les entreprises TPE
PME qui rencontre des difficultés de
recrutement pour construire un parcours
de formation un parcours d'adaptation et
donc ce sont toutes ces solutions qui
qui vont permettre agir sur les tensions
de recrutement après il y a un une
condition de réussite c'est
l'anticipation plus vite on mobilise nos
services et plus vite effectivement on
est en capacité de poser un diagnostic
de projeter sur des solutions et
mobiliser notre réseau pour vous
accompagner alors justement puisque vous
avez des dirigeants quand vous entendez
les propos de Kera comment vous
réagissez est-ce que vous connaissez ces
solutions ces différentes initiatives de
Pôle emploi en tant que dirigeant et
dans le besoin de nouvelles
collaborateurs en ce qui me concentre
j'en connais quelques unes mais je
connais pas l'étendue de tous les
programmes parce que mon métier c'est
pas d'être un métier de recruteur à
plein temps donc je fais avant tout
dirigeant et entreprises de 40 personnes
donc voilà il y a des activités
quotidiennes qui sont importantes en
tout cas moi mon organisation c'est de
c'est de d'être quasiment recrutement
permanent en fait même si on n'a pas un
poste ouvert en tout cas en des annonces
qui passent et dès qu'on voit
effectivement un profil qui nous
intéresse c'est tout de suite essayer de
mettre en place de le contacter puis
éventuellement faire du recrutement donc
j'écoutais ce que vous dit avec
attention et c'est vrai que c'est
extrêmement important on a un candidat
quand on soit beaucoup de CV parfois sur
des annonces en soi beaucoup de CV mais
des CV qui correspondent pas forcément à
nos besoins si on a effectivement un
candidat qui va démontrer l'intérêt pour
vous pour votre activité votre métier
effectivement là ça fait la différence
et même on va dire si coche pas tout à
fait toutes les cases bah en fait
l'intérêt va faire que voilà il va
remonter on va dire sur le haut en fait
de la pile en tout cas on va pouvoir
engager cette interaction et
effectivement pour nous c'est c'est
super en fait parce que trouver une
candidature à travers des DCV parfois
qu'on reçoit c'est extrêmement compliqué
on a parfois peu de temps pour pour les
analyser et ben parfois voilà on passe à
côté de d'excellents candidats Kevin
Jean-Paul c'est une réalité que vous
connaissez vous avez pas le temps de de
finalement vous engager pleinement dans
complètement alors moi je gère pas
directement ce que j'ai collaboratrice
qui interviennent dessus on est 18
personnes aujourd'hui et
le retour que j'ai et je vois passer de
temps en temps effectivement c'est on a
95% de CV qu'on reçoit mais qui ne sont
absolument pas adaptés avec des CV ou
des notes de motivation qui sont passés
qui correspondent effectivement à tout
le monde et je m'aperçois que les
déclics que l'on peut avoir c'est
simplement sur une phrase sur un mot sur
quelque chose qui tient ça ça
effectivement ça me correspond et je
dirais que toute l'attention que peut
avoir un candidat et la dernière
recrutement qu'on a eu c'est une
personne qui est qui est arrivé à
l'entretien et qui avait passé du temps
sur notre site internet qui connaissait
les produits presque aussi bien que nous
et qui avait vraiment préparé son
entretien et qu'elle va vraiment envie
de venir et je crois que c'est vraiment
ça c'est manifesté l'envie et quand on
met manifeste cet envie en face j'irai
d'un recruteur il y a 50 plus de 50% du
chemin qui est fait quoi clairement ça
c'est le premier point et le deuxième
point nous dans notre essence puisque on
travaille et on intervient dans dans le
monde du handicap on essaye aussi de
d'enorer également de faire du
recrutement inclusif et en local autour
de sur trappes serait en cours sur la
verrière etc
et donc des personnes qui sont éloignées
de l'emploi et sur les quartiers et là
notre grosse difficulté j'ai envie d'en
faire plus la grande difficulté c'est
d'arriver à les identifier les trouver
et on ne peut pas passer à temps fou à
solliciter toutes les structures les
associations etc et mon rêve ça serait
d'avoir demain une sorte de guichet
unique dans lequel on dit voilà on a le
besoin là et une personne qui derrière
dit on profite on va les solliciter tel
endroit tel ou telle personne et nous
faire gagner énormément de temps et
efficacité pour nous mais pour les
candidats aussi c'est celui-ci elles
existent les conseillers en évolution
professionnelle donc qui accompagne les
demandeurs d'emploi dans leur recherche
d'emploi vous avez par exemple à trappe
l'agence le Pôle emploi avec lequel vous
êtes en relation une équipe dédiée pour
l'accompagnement des personnes qui
relèvent des quartiers prioritaires de
la ville également des équipes
qui accompagnent des personnes en
situation de handicap et donc c'est
c'est pour une politique effectivement
de recrutement inclusive les
interlocuteurs des dédiée qui accompagne
ces populations les plus éloignées ou en
fragilité en tout cas pour qui voilà en
se mobilise et on en fait on mobilise
notre offre de service vous pouvez aussi
être en relation avec ses équipes là et
on peut organiser des sessions de
recrutement chaque agence a également
ouvre ses portes aux entreprises pour
les accueillir vous offrir cette tribune
là
de communiquer autour de votre
entreprise votre marque employeur vos
projets vos besoins de recrutement et
puis rencontrer des candidats également
donc les sessions de recrutement elle
cesser notre quotidien donc
chaque agence est un lieu d'opportunité
de service donc ces opportunités c'est
aussi cette opportunité de rencontrer
des candidats
avec le Pôle emploi de Trappes pour des
AFPR voilà et plutôt très bien
fonctionné c'est collaboration après je
note deux points tout en étant en accord
avec mes confrères je note deux points
sur ce que Virginie et qui a grandi d'un
côté il y a l'innovation et l'approche
innovante des processus de recrutement
que vous avez ça c'est très important
du travail bien sûr une approche les
profils classiques oui mais on veut des
candidats qui apporte quelque chose en
plus tu as une vision qui ont quelque
chose de d'original qui va vraiment
faire le déclic parce que les profils on
en a plusieurs et en plus des profils
qui ne correspondent pas qui ont donc ça
ça passe toujours mais le deuxième point
c'est au niveau de la communication et
l'outil numérique les candidats c'est un
candidat de plus en plus les contacts
des recruteurs directement il présente
leur profil ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils
aimeraient faire et le lien avec ce que
nous on fait et ça ça touche ça c'est
déjà le Candia le profil va bien parce
qu'il a étudié et en plus il vous
contacte spontanément et ça ça voilà ça
ça intéresse ça crée la discussion
même si parfois on n'a pas une solution
tout de suite des questions des
problématiques à mettre des stagiaires
ou des jeunes on en a toujours on peut
discuter ensemble et voir ce qu'on peut
faire avec LinkedIn la proximité entre
un patron et finalement un candidat à ne
jamais être aussi intéressantes
c'est-à-dire que on peut directement
c'est plus les process mails comme avant
on peut directement les toucher
directement se rendre visible voilà
c'est une stratégie marketing enfin qui
peut mettre en place et chacun doit le
faire parce que finalement ça fait
partie du jeu je pense aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir trouver le job de ses rêves
parce que trouver un emploi c'est une
chose et puis on le sait pour qu'un
candidat je prends ma casquette
d'employeur mais pour qu'un candidat
perdu et finalement qui puisse évoluer
par la suite il faut qu'il aime ce qu'il
fait enfin son quotidien c'est que il
soit passionné pour que ça ne devienne
pas finalement juste un travail mais qui
prennent plaisir parce qu'en plus on est
dans des métiers je pense informatique
mais toujours en évolution donc on doit
monter en compétences en permanence on
pourra en parler d'un montant en
compétences mais du coup pour pouvoir en
compétences naturellement il faut aimer
ce qu'on fait parce que sinon c'est
compliqué ça devient une démarche de
plus en plus compliquée et avec le temps
qui s'alourdit donc je pense que c'est
à une chose qu'on peut dire ou candidats
on en a quelques-uns qui vont arriver ce
que les recruteurs responsables
répondent toujours quand ils sont
soliftés spontanément et proprement il y
a pas de raison de ne pas répondre
à des candidats motivés dynamiques et
puis bienveillant Cara voulu dire un mot
oui vous parliez effectivement
d'accessibilité de liens des réseaux
sociaux qui favorisent cette proximité
il y a un levier également un outil qui
peut permettre d'entretenir cette
proximité c'est l'immersion
professionnelle et cette immersion ça
permet dans le cas dans un cadre
juridique sur une convention de stage
qui est signé avec le Pôle Emploi
d'accueillir un demandeur d'emploi dans
le cas d'une découverte des métiers pour
initier une un projet de recrutement une
embauche et donc ouvrir aussi les portes
de l'entreprise à de potentiels
candidats mais ça permet effectivement
peut-être d'accompagner des transitions
professionnelles et peut-être de
récupérer ensuite la compétence à
l'issue peut-être d'un parcours de
formation mais également de détecter des
potentiels et donc ça c'est aussi un
service qui est à votre main qui a votre
disposition et accueillir de manière
régulière des candidats c'est aussi
mettre en visibilité votre entreprise
vos besoins vos projets communiquer sur
votre marque en employeur et permettre à
des candidats de se projeter dans du
réel
allez on va conclure ce premier plateau
tout simplement comment recruter en 2023
comment vous allez assurer ces
recrutements et est-ce que vous pouvez
déjà partager peut-être des fois sur
lesquels vous recrutez à l'heure
actuelle alors des postes on en a on en
a quelques-uns en cours des
administrateurs systèmes et réseaux des
commerciaux des postes aussi supports
tels que comptable assistante
commerciale donc ça c'est les postes qui
sont disponibles aujourd'hui dans le
groupe c'est 150 postes ouverts
aujourd'hui partout en France mais voilà
nous on en a une dizaine dans dans les
Yvelines pour appeler Coignières et
Asnières Versailles Versailles
Boulogne-Billancourt voilà et
j'en oublie une autre Saint-Cloud c'est
la dernière en date alors comment
recruter en 2023
la thématique je suis pas sûr d'avoir
toujours les bonnes recettes mais en
tout cas qu'est-ce que je fais au
quotidien c'est effectivement on les
annonce on a des candidatures et c'est
tous les jours c'est quotidiennement
regarder toutes les candidatures qui
arrivent parce que dans candidature là
il y a peut-être notre futur pépite donc
ça c'est un premier point et même si on
n'a pas prévu de recruter immédiatement
bah parfois on recrute on va dire un
petit peu plus parce qu'on sait qu'on en
aura besoin dans les dans les semaines
ou dans les mois qui suivent et puis
c'est aussi comme c'est Madame en fait
c'est d'accueillir on est l'entreprise
qui est très accueillante donc nous on a
on prend beaucoup de stagiaire dès la 4e
pourquoi et on fait découvrir
l'entreprise on fait découvrir notre
métier est-ce que parfois ça crée des
vocations et donc c'est effectivement ce
que vous disiez c'est en accueillant de
bah des stagiaires dès la 4e et puis
jusque au bac + 5 et puis parfois en
reconversion également ça permet de
montrer l'entreprise
ça permet de montrer notre métier et
puis encore une fois parfois de voilà de
déclencher quelques quelques belles
réussites et quelques recrutement on a
un collaborateur on a fêté ses 20 ans il
y a quelques semaines mais il est arrivé
chez nous par un stage voilà il y a 20
ans en reconversion donc un exemple de
l'immersion professionnelle exactement
Jean-Paul oui bon dans la même logique
on est adepte depuis très longues années
de j'irai de l'alternance et donc on est
certain alternants qui finalement à bout
de leurs achats sont restés et dont sont
devenus des sont devenus des
collaborateurs recrutement c'est en
fonction de l'évolution de l'activité et
de nous effectivement de nos besoins et
puis actuellement on est effectivement
là on a recrute on vient de défectuer un
recrutement avec une personne
je dirais en assistant commercial qui
démarre le 2 janvier et on a en ce
moment un recrutement également ouvert
pour un poste de technicien atelier
voilà dans un fabrication donc sur
trappe Kevin
2023 on recrute côté eurica des
consultants innovations et avec
airbnadium on ne recrute des
développeurs web on est vraiment en
recherche et bon alors la stratégie on a
pas été très bon en 2022 mais je pense
que avec l'expérience les collaborations
avec les partenaires territoriaux le
Pôle Emploi
Sky emploi aussi 51 Yvelines voilà ça
marche plutôt bien au big to avec Sky
emploi on a recruté notre dernière
collaboratrice et ça se fait plutôt bien
va passer et avec Pôle emploi c'est des
trucs qui ont marché voilà l'idée pour
nous c'est d'aller vraiment soit vers
nos partenaires soit directement dans le
berceau dans les écoles pas des stages
ou l'alternance juste pour préciser le
pictour c'est un événement qui est
organisé par BPI France en collaboration
avec 50 ans en Yvelines qui s'est tenu
au belodrome National je crois que
c'était en septembre dernier le 20
septembre dernier et justement ils
organisaient le l'événement phare de 50
ans en Yvelines le empiste pour l'emploi
le gros job dating organisé par 50 ans
Virginie votre avis sur comment recruter
en 2023 alors je sais que vous c'est
plus différent vous avez une position
différente de formatrice donc en fait
justement on en parlait ce que
effectivement on accompagne aussi
notamment Axel dans la communication
numérique en fait je crois qu'il y a une
chose qui est importante c'est que dans
les annonces on peut pas toujours
véhiculer des choses hyper des éléments
hyper essentiels pour des candidats qui
est l'histoire de l'entreprise ces
valeurs ses engagements et moi je
recommande à tous les dirigeants d'un
carnés leur entreprise sur les réseaux
sociaux aussi et transmettre ça à
travers leur histoire à travers leur
parcours à travers leurs anecdote et du
moins en tout cas de pas rester sur des
annonces très froides et travailler
cette marque employeur à travers les
émotions parce que derrière il y a des
humains et en fait on rejoint un patron
c'est pas pour rien le thème de
l'émission C'est je partage son avis
parce que quand je parlais d'envie des
l'envie des candidats entre l'entreprise
il faut aussi leur donner envie et ça
c'est essentiel et je vais découvrir par
exemple Virginie parce que c'est très
récent c'est à monter une dizaine de
jours ou effectivement on a travaillé
ensemble sur notre communication
numérique d'opposition linkedinine etc
et en incarnant et en faisant les choses
de façon beaucoup plus
personnelle la part du dirigeant moi
j'ai découvert par exemple surprises que
mes potes qui aujourd'hui faisaient
200-300-300 vues posent bien travailler
ensemble et après de 6000 vues du jour
au lendemain donc ça fonctionne donc
j'ai pas encore le candidats
en 2023 peuvent passer donc plus sur les
réseaux sociaux pour conclure Kiara Pôle
emploi du coup les actions font
poursuivre en 2021 alors les actions
vont poursuivre en 2023 ils vont
s'intensifier avec la mise en place de
mes événements emploi donc chaque pôle
emploi organisera avec votre concours
des sessions de recrutement pour
favoriser cette intermédiation c'est
également l'accès à la formation pour
développer les compétences des candidats
c'est également des semaines dédiées
thématiques pour mettre en visibilité
aussi des secteurs qui recrutent et donc
la semaine du numérique on va démarrer
en janvier par cette semaine du
numérique avec cet ambition cet objectif
de mettre en visibilité les opportunités
du secteur et donc on a besoin de vous
pour voilà pour parler de vos
recrutements de vos entreprises de votre
marque employeur et puis susciter des
vocations merci à vous d'être venu sur
ce plateau pour parler justement des
évolutions et puis de cette conjoncture
qui s'annonce au niveau de l'emploi en
Ian Rolland dirigeant de xéphis
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Jean-Paul
Mignard dirigeant la seule Kevin
gifenchou Eurêka et RD manager et puis
Kera et drief directrice du bureau Pôle
emploi de Rambouillet
[Musique]
et demain dans le 7 8 nous parlerons des
perspectives économiques pour cette
nouvelle année 2023 avant de refermer
cette édition un nouveau coup d'œil par
la météo
[Musique]
et après la douceur de ce weekend
nouvelle ans retour à des températures
plus normal demain le ciel sera nuageux
le matin avec quelques éclairs s'il fera
6 degrés à Rambouillet Versailles Houdan
5 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie des
conditions similaires l'après-midi avec
un thermomètre qui grimpe légèrement
comptez 10 degrés dans le nord et le
centre du département il devrait faire 9
degrés à Rambouillet ce mardi 3 janvier
nous fêterons les Geneviève voilà c'est
la fin de ce 7 8 merci de votre fidélité
une nouvelle fois très bonne année 2023
au nom de toute l'équipe de TV 78 très
belle soirée à tous
[Musique]